e
herkese merhaba Bence sağlık bir sanat
artısıyım genelde bunu ortamlarda
söylediğim zaman sana tarzı kimdir ya da
ne iş yapar da cevaplamak zorunda
kalıyorum Vicdan böyle başlayacağım sana
tarihçiliği Aslında benim çok severek
kazandığım çalıştığım bir alandı bu
alandan mezun olmadan önce bir de herkes
bana diyordu ki sana tarzı olursan işsiz
kalırsın haklı çıktılar ve mezun
olduktan hemen sonra İşsiz kaldım evde O
kadar sıkıldım ki dedim ki artık sana
tanem vazgeçeyim başka alanlarda iş
aramaya başlayayım ama başka alanlarda
sanat tarihine ne olduğunu bilmedikleri
için beni işe almadılar ve sana
tarihçiliğine herkese anlatmak zorunda
kalıyordum yollardaki o kaç yıllık işte
siz mezar hırsızlığı yapıyor musunuz
İşte benim Kaçak ne aradığın var gibi
sorular geliyor ve ben de sana Tanrı
tanıtmak ve sevdirmek adına 2016 yılında
sanatın tarihi de bir sayfa açtım
Twitter'da daha sonra Instagram'dan mı
sayfa açtım ve basitçe sanatlarını
tanıtmak istediğim için basit çi yazılar
yazdım ve eğlenceli olmasına dikkat
ettim ve süreç şöyle gelişti bir anda
insanlar ilgi gösterdiler ve bu sırada
çok fazla sorular gelmeye başladı bu
sorulardan en fazla gelin asla Sanat
nedir sorusu Ben de bugün bunu kendimce
anlatacağım Çünkü Sanat nedir in kimse
bir cevabını veremez Boom Beach sanatın
öyküsünün yazarı Boom Beach şöyle
söylüyor dilin nasıl ortaya çıktığını
bilmiyoruz Tıpkı sanatın Das ortaya
çıktığı bilmediğimiz gibi ve biz sanat
tarihinde sanatı anlatırken Elbette ki
kuramsal bazı şeylere başvuruyoruz Coşku
için
kuramsal bir tanımı var ama herkes Bence
sanat diye başlayan cümleler kurmaya çok
seviyor Ben de çok seviyorum ve Bence
sanat bir başkaldırı ve sanat ve sanatçı
her zaman her dönemi baş kaldırarak
başlatmış Aslında bunu yazdığım kitaplar
da yazdığım yazılarda çalışmalarımda ve
seminerlerinde anlattıkça dikkat ettiğim
bir unsur olarak karşıma çıkmasıyla
çalışmaya başladım bir başlıklı
başkaldırı başlığı ve sanatın başkaldırı
olmasıyla ilgili benim alanım daha çok
Batı sanatı Batı resim sanatı bu Batı
resim sanatının modern sanata kadar olan
bir macerası var Ben sizlere bu Macerayı
nasıl bir başkaldırı üzerinden ilerliyor
bunu göstermeye çalışacağım Öncelikle
Orta Çağ Avrupa'sında
ortaçağ sanatı diye bir sanat var ve
ortaçağ sanatı Aslında hepimizin
ilkokuldan ya da liseden bildiğimiz bir
şey var ortaçağ karanlık dönem
engizisyon mahkemeleri var Cadı ağları
var bu işte insanlar Cennetten toprak
satın alıyor gibi bazı bilgiler var
böyle bir dönemin sanatı nasıl olur din
temalı olur ve din ne olacak bir şey
olur biz ilk eserde
birincil resmi görüyoruz codes kalk
incirinin bir kapak resmini görüyoruz
Normalde ortaçağ insanla basitçe dini
anlatabilmek adına var Bu resimler
insanlar kiliselere girdikleri zaman ya
da ellerine birincil Aldıkları zaman iyi
sayı havaleleri Meryem'i görsünler diye
ya da Azizleri görsünler diye var
okuma-yazma oranı o kadar düşük ki hatta
yok denilebilecek kadar az insanlar
kiliselerin içine girdikleri zaman
İncili tevratı kutsal metinleri görsel
bir şekilde karşılığında bulabiliyorlar
bir şekilde resim okuyorlar ve daha
sonra bu Orta Çağ resmine şöyle bir
kısaca bakacak olursak anatominin
olmadığını perspektif olmadığını
herhangi bir Doğa anlatım olmadığını
görüyoruz Aslında resim sadece yüzeysel
ve insanlar aslında korkutmak için var
İsa'ya bakarsanız biraz hani onun o
korkunç gözleri daha insanlar bu işin
ciddi olduğunu düşün her yerde var daha
sonra bir aydınlık dönemi geliyor ve bu
aydınlık dönemi Rönesans antik Roma'nın
yeniden ortaya çıkışı antik Roma'nın
yeniden doğuşu rinascimento yeniden
doğuş ölen bir kişinin yeniden doğuş
anlamına geliyor ve antikçağ Yunan ve
Roma metinlerine okuyan floransalı lar
Artık yeni bir dil geliştirmeye
başlıyorlar ve hepimizin tanıdığı meşhur
bir floransalı var Leonardo Da Vinci iki
tane eserini gösteriyorum şu anda slayt
ta birisi hepimizin bildiği monalisa
hiçbir şifresi Yok onu söyleyeyim Diğer
tarafta da son akşam yemeği Onun da
hiçbir şifresi Yok onu da söyleyeyim
yani bunlar aslında biraz da kurgu Roman
yazarlarının geliştirdikleri Teoriler ve
kurgular Hatta davran Kendisi de
söylüyor Ben sadece kurgu yaptım diye
bizim Bu resimlerde görmek istediğimiz
şey aslında ortaçağ bir başkaldırır
Çünkü ortaçağ karanlığına ve soyut
kavramına gerçekçi bir başkaldırı
görüyoruz sahne baktığımızda son Akşam
yemeğinde
Bu sadece havaleleri gerçekçi bir ışığın
altında görürüz havariler Antik Yunan
Antik Yunan filozoflarına benzedikleri
gibi bir yandan da o kaotik ortamda
üçerli gruplar halinde bir düzen
oluştururlar bir anda da monalisa var
Mona Lisa dan çok kısaca bahsedeceğim
günümüzde telefonlarımızda odaklama diye
bir şey var O da alıyoruz arka tarafı
Flow yapıyor Ön taraftaki figürü
netleştirmiyor bu İtalya'da ilk ahşap
panel üzerine yağlıboya Eser bunlar önce
ahşap panel üzerine yağlıboya ya da
herhangi bir panel üzerine yağlıboya
kullanılmadı Leonardo Da Vinci arkaya
eritme tekniği dediğimiz su mato diye
bir teknik uyguluyor ve arka tarafı flu
ön tanıtır ki figürü daha net yapar
kendi sözdür zaten arka plasti olur ya
da full olursa ön taraftaki figür daha
da öne çıkacaktır diyor ve bu gibi
gerçekçilikle
ortaçağın o soyut kavramların a meydan
okuyor floransalı ve bu daha sonra başka
bir floransalı Roma'ya gidiyor ve
Roma'ya gittikten sonra artık başka bir
dile ihtiyaç olduğunu fark ediyor bu
değil tekrar kutsal metinlerdeki
sahneleri kutsal bir görünümle duvarlara
yansıtmak mikelenjelonun sistina şapeli
ne yaptığı resimler bunu temel alır
kendisi Leonardo başkaldırır Aslında
ondan da biraz beslen SD mesela hani
havalelerin Antik Yunan filozoflarına
benzediğini söylemiştim ya bu noktada
sağ tarafta gördüğünüz Adem'e ruhun
üflenmesi sahnesindeki Tanrı'ya
baktığınız zaman daha çok kime
benzediğini söyleyebiliriz zeus'a Yani
bu noktada hala bir antik dönemlerden
beslenme söz konusu Ama artık o
Rönesans'ın gerçekçiliği doğal gölge
dışı tamamen kaybolmuş durumda Biz
burada İki resimde de çok yoğun bir ışık
kullanımı görüyoruz mavinin ya da diğer
renkleri çok abartıldığını görüyoruz
mikelenjelo Bu resimleri yapana kadar
herhangi bir Hey res bu yoktu daha çok
heykel çalıştı Bu yüzden kendisinde bir
lafı var İyi resim heykel benzeyenler
diye burada heykeli misin yoğun kaslı
Hatta gong içinde bunlara fitnesscı iyi
sağlar Ve Tanrı figürleri der daha sonra
başka bir Romalı ressam kendisinin adı
mikelenjelo oyuna ancak biz onu
karavancı olarak biliyoruz Karabacak
köyünde doğduğu için
Michelangelo merisi de karavancı kendisi
mikelenjelonun O çok kutsal
sahnelerinden sıkılıyor Ve kutsal
sahneleri gerçek indirgemeye çalışıyor
zaten mikelenjelonun sistine şapel ile
giren inananlar demişler kim inceliyor
iziwin o yani kutsal olan ancak kar
Avcı'ya göre böyle bir kutsiyet yok
Karalar Joe bir çete lideriydi
cinayetleri işlediği hırsızlık yaptığı
gaspçılık yap yaptı ve çok gibi
dolandırıcı ydı onun hayata bakış açısı
çok karanlık ve gerçekçi olduğu için
resimleri de bir o kadar karanlık ve
gerçekçiydi 21 yüzyıl etkileyerek Barok
sanatı başlattı the karavancı aslında
mikelenjelonun kutsallığına
başkaldırıyor diyor ki ben hiç
gökyüzünde süzülen melekler Gökyüzüne
doğru çıkan meryemler görmedim benim
gerçekliği bu dünya dur diyor ve Biz
buradaki havalelerin dilencilerden ve
şarapçılar dan model alındığını
biliyoruz karavaçyo genellikle bunu
yapıyor ve bunu yaparken de Vatikan'a
başkaldırıyor Vatikan o dönemde çok
zengin ve romanın arka sokaklarında
yaşayan romalıları görmezden geliyor bu
yüzden dek araba Joe sokakta yaşayan
dilencileri fahişeleri şarapçıları
suçları gaspçıları kutsal kişiler olarak
kilisenin duvarlarını asıyor ve bu Barok
sanat bir Yüzyıl boyunca 17 yüzyıl
boyunca
Fransa'da İspanya'da İngiltere'de
Hollanda ve Belçika'da çok güçlü bir
şekilde kullanılıyor daha sonra bu
ciddiyetten sıkılan bu kızlar bir rokoko
dönemi başlatacak lar ruku dönemi
eşittir Soylu şenliği olarak
düşünebilirsiniz yani soylarının Aşk
üçgenleri aldatma sahneleri gibi
düşünebilirsiniz Bu eseri çok kısa
analiz edeceğim Çok eğlenceli bir eser
Frog onardın Beye söyle brook'un çok
önemli temsilcilerinden Kendisi şimdi
buraya bir orman gibi düşünebilirsiniz
ama Fransızlar kendi saraylarının
bahçelerine böyle ormanlar yapıyorlar ki
daha rahat buluşup kaçamak yapıp
yapabilirsin ler burada merkezde pembe
kıyafetler içerisinde bir kadın 8
görüyoruz kadın figürünün bir Salıncaklı
olduğunu görüyoruz salıncak dön ekleyin
ya da dengesizliği mi sembolüdür
kadının ayakkabısına Bakın terliğine
bakın ayağından fırlamış ayaktan çıkan
kadın terliği cinselliğe davettir
arkasında yaşlı kocasının onu
salladığını görüyoruz Peki önünde kim
var çalıların arasında genç aşığı var
genç arşına eteğinin altını gösteriyor
Aslında bu merkezdeki kalın ve bu aynı
zamanda kadının sahne konumlandırılması
nı yine sembolize ederek anlatabiliriz
mesela kadının yüzü nereye dönüş
sevgilisine Ve karşısındaki Eros heykeli
ne aşk Tanrısı'nın heykeline aç Tanrısı
ne yapıyor Sessiz ol kocan duyacak diyor
arka tarafta da Hristiyan Melekleri var
Yani dinine ve kocasına sırtını dönem Bu
kadının hikayesi anlatılıyor Soylu
şenliği ekmek bulamıyorlarsa pasta
yesinler in resimsel karşılığı Aslında
ve bundan jine çok sıkılanlar var hatta
o kadar sıkılıyorlar ki bu Devrim sadece
resim anlamında gerçekleşmiyor bu Devrim
hepimizin hemen hemen bildiği meşhur
Fransız İhtilali
1789 Fransız ihtilalinden önce ressamlar
artık bu rokokonun özellikle Fransız
ressamlar bro konu Ciddiyetsiz liğine
baş kaldırmak için hatta genel olarak Bu
soylulara baş kaldırmak için halkın
İsyan ettiğini görüyoruz halkın İsyan
etmesinin ardından ve Şu Karşıda
vermelerinin ardından
rokoko döneminde eser Sipariş eden ya da
Eser yapan herkes ya giyotine ya da
Sürgüne gönderiliyor ve yeni başlayan
dönem tekrar rönesansı ölçülen ancak
rönesanstan farklı olarak doğrudan Antik
Yunan filozoflarının kullanan Xani
klasikçiler Neo Klasik dönem ve bu eser
Bu arada sürece şovenist diyor ki
sistine şapeli nden biri karşımıza çıkan
en güzel eser diyor daha ciddi tonlar
görürüz kahramanlık burada merkezdedir
Mesela Sokrates burada idam ediliyor ve
sohbet et şunu biliyor o uzandık a de
aslında onu öldürecek olan Kadı ama hiç
kadar bakıyor mu öyle birisi sadece
alelade bir bardak su uzatıyormuş da onu
alıyormuş gibi ve burada aslında Sadece
kahramanlık vurgulanıyor Kanca kısa süre
sonra ikinci bir Fransız İhtilali
gerçekleşecek bu 1830 devrimidir ve 1830
Devrimi'nde bu yine ciddi ya da bu
fotoğraf iks onlardan sıkılan ressamlar
romansı Coşkun hissettirebilmek için
resimler yapmaya başlıyorlar biz buna
romantizm diyoruz yani romantizm
dediğimde genellikle işte böyle
ilişkilerdeki romantikliği anla insanlar
ama aslında öyle değil romansı Coşkun
hissetmemizi isteyen ressamların yaptığı
resimler Bu resim 1863'te kadar
yasaklanıyor yani yasaklı bir eser ve
Hani özgürlük eseri olması da o da
yasaklanmasıyla birlikte zıt sonda
anlatacağım eserle bağlaya bileceğim bir
kompozisyona sahip burada özgürlük
anıtı'na da ilham olan bir kadın figürü
görüyoruz elini Fransız Bayram tutuyor
ve mavi beyaz ve kırmızı renklerinin
genel olarak resme da hakim olduğunu
görüyorsunuz Victor Hugo'nun Sefiller
kitabından çok referans alır Bu eser O
yüzden de romantik bir eserdir arkada
Notre Dame katedrali ya da şu iki
tabancalı çocuğa baktığımız zaman onu
sefillerdeki göre şu oldu bu destan
söylüyor ve bütün bu
isyanlardan devrimlerden sıkılan
Fransızlar biraz da dünyayı gezmek
istiyorlar ve biraz da bu kasvete bir
başkaldırı oluyor aslında Napolyon'un
Mısır'a almasından sonra yanında da bir
bilim ordusu götürmesiyle yeni bir
serüvene başlamıştı Fransızlar ve
ortadoğu'ya kuzey Afrika'ya Anadolu'ya
gelmişler ve oryantalist dönem
başlatmışlar the ancak oryantalizm
Batı'nın doğu'ya bakışını yansıtır Yani
bu resimler gerçekçi değildir Çünkü
Mesela biz resimde Cami içinde özel
olarak korumalarıyla Birlikte ayrı bir
seccadede namaz kılan bir figür
görüyoruz Bu gerçekçi değildir aynı
zamanda cemaate daha yakın olan bir
çıplak figür görüyoruz Bu çıplak figür
de asla camide bulunamaz yani Canon
Burada kendi gördüklerini mekanları
kurgulayarak Aslında yansıtıyor ve bütün
bunların ardından bütün Bu gördüğünüz
bütün akımlara baş kaldırıp modern çağ
başlatacak yeni bir ressam ortaya
çıkıyor mane mane eseri kırda yemek
1863'te sergileniyor salon Paris'te ve
salon Paris'te sergilendiği nde 3.
Napolyon eserin karşısında geçiyor
suratına istiyor daha sonra a o dönem
eleştirmenleri şöyle yazarlar salon
Paris sergisine girdiniz yedikten sonra
sesi dinleyin modelin eserlerine doğru
gidersiniz diye
diye ayıklıyor varmış ya da şükür
edenler Resmin üstüne tükürenler oluyor
resmin karşısında kalka atanlar oluyor
çünkü bu resim Onlara göre çok ayıp
çünkü daha önce hiç halktan birini
çıplak olarak karşılarında görmediler
Evet devini çıplak olarak gördük ya da
venüsler gördük Afrodit resimleri ya da
heykelleri gördük çıplak olarak Ama
buradaki kadın victorem Moren kendisi
model ressam Paris'te de oldukça meşhur
bir bu ve manenin Aslında hayatına da
biraz bakmamız gerekiyor mane babası
Yargıç ve kendisinin de
hukukla ilgili bir iş yapmasını istiyor
ancak babasına başkaldırıyor evliliği
bilim baş kaldı ailesinin istemediği bir
kadınla evlenir ve mane bu resmi
seçerken akademi'nin bütün kurallarını
reddediyor size gösterdiğim bütün
dönemlerde Akademi genel olarak Bazı
kurallar koyar Mesela örnek vereyim 22
ölçülerde bir tuval seçerseniz o tuvalin
içerisinde sadece dil resmi yada Savaş
resmi yerleştirebilirsiniz Bu resmin
ölçüleri 222 üniversite öğrencisi iki
fahişeyle birlikte kırda alem yapıyorlar
ve hiç kimsenin ilgilenmediği şarabı
kendinden geçmeyi zevki temsil eden
üzümlerin olduğu bir sepet arkada yıkan
Bir kadın eserin ilk adı banyo ve bu
eser sergiden kaldırılıyor sergiden
10'dan sonra bütün genç ressamlar
Akademi reddederek monet'nin peşinden
gitmeye karar veriyorlar ve imparator 3.
napolyon'a mektuplar yazmaya başlıyorlar
yazdıkları mektuplarda o kadar ısrar
ediyorlar ki Napolyon dayanamıyor ve
reddedilenler sergisi diye bir sergi
açıyor
reddedilenler sergisini altı haftada
500.000 insan ziyaret ediyor Bu bir
rekor ve herkes Bu eseri gelme görmeye
geldiklerinde aynı zamanda halka
liderlik eden özgürlük eserini de
görüyorlar sanat tarihi daha da
özgürleşiyor bundan önceki dönemde
ressamlar sipariş alıp öyle Eser
üretirken Yani biraz zanaat ve sanat
içiçe geçmişken artık sanatçı bir eser
ortaya koyacak ve daha sonra o esere
göre sipariş olacak yani sanat için
sanat zihniyetinin doğuşudur Bu resim ve
mani aynı zamanda bir kopya ressamıdır u
Müzesi'nde kopya ressamlığı ya bu aynı
zamanda tip İsyan onun ya da rondonun
resimlerindeki kompozisyonu kopyalayarak
bu resmi çıkartmış ve modern ve Hale
getirmiştir yani ondan bir yandan da
beslenir Eskiden beslenir akademikten
beslenir ama kademe reddeder bundan
sonra nasıl bir macera başlayacak bundan
sonra sana tarihinde pek çok besin
karşımıza çıkacak Empresyonizm Sembol
izim ekspresyonizm yılı arada
post-empresyonizm
Dadaizm fütürizm Kübizm rayonizm soyut
sanat artık baş kaldıranların dönem
başlayacak modern sanatçı ileriye dönük
sanatçıdır
1863 ten 1960'a kadar hangi sanatçı
ismini biliyorsanız Kangoo Daily Renault
Madrid hangisini duyduysanız hepsi
modern sanatçı kategorisine girer ve
Hepsi kendi dönemlerine kendi
sanatsal düşüncelerine o dönemin
sanatsal düşüncelerine bu bu olarak
anarşist sanatçı kategorisinde
sınıflandırılırlar dinlediğiniz için çok
teşekkür ederim ve son olarak şunu
ekleyeyim Burası reddedilenler servis
miydi Ve bu reddedilenler sergisi baş
kaldıranların eserlerinin sergilendiği
bir salon Oldu oldu ve güzel
reddedilenler sergisinde baş
kaldıranların resimlerinin sergilenmesi
reddedilenlerin çağını başlattı Umarım
reddedilen bugün eserler resimler bir
gün bu bir başkaldırı yla isimlerini
gelecekte daha çok duyabilirler burada
çok güzel bir dünya var çünkü ve sanat
tarihinde bu bu mu resimlerin
anlatılması bize bambaşka perspektifler
sunabilir bambaşka Hikayeler var
bambaşka anlamlar çıkarıp yeni bir bir
öğrenim tarzı elde edebiliriz sanatla
kalın diyorum dinlediğiniz için çok
teşekkür ederim Tekrar abone ol